what's going on everybody welcome to
another tkinter tutorial video in this
video I'm gonna be showing you guys how
to convert your tkinter application to
an executable so I know I said I was
going to do the trading next but I want
to go ahead and get the executable out
of the way and then we'll talk about
trading and all that so I've held off on
doing the conversion to an executable
because doing doing the conversion can
bring in all kinds of bugs so what we
may encounter in this conversion may not
be exactly what you might encounter in a
conversion as well I mean if you do the
exact same code as me you should
encounter the exact same issues but
otherwise like if you add more code to
this or as we add trading and we bring
in a the various API connection scripts
and stuff like that to do automated
trading and that kind of stuff
as we bring in more and more stuff it's
only gonna get more and more complex so
I figured now is that kind of a good
time to go ahead and add it so first of
all we're going to be using CX freeze
let me get to it here CX freeze CCS
freeze download so if you just do like a
Google search or something like that
you'll find yourself on this page right
here now the only problem with this is
apparently the what you might get from
UM from the downloads is you get a get a
version that isn't patched and even
though it says you know the last version
4.33 supposedly the superior place to
download and this is where I've always
got mine is from this website here so
I'll put this link in the description I
share this website a lot it's just but
it's just for Windows binaries so if
you're not on Windows then you would
probably use this method but we're
apt-get python - the X freeze probably
or something along those lines so this
is what we're going to use so download
the applicable version to yourself make
sure you get 4.3.3
and obviously match bit version
and python version once you have that
you're ready to actually write the code
so this right here tkinter vid 28 is our
current code and what we want to do is
write a conversion script for our code
here now I do have a more much more
basic video on CX freeze so if you want
to know a little bit more about how CX
freeze actually works do check out that
video if I remember to I will put a link
in the description with that let's go
ahead and and get started here so the
first thing we want to do is just
basically cover into your you know
wherever the directory of your script is
and we want to just make a blank script
so I'm going to take intro and what I'm
going to go ahead and do is just
copy/paste intro just to have a file and
we're going to call this one setup so
the actual file name here is setup dot
pi and I'm going to go ahead and open
edit with idle here whoops and we'll
just delete that for now and we'll come
up here and now we're going to do the
various imports that we need so first we
need to import C X underscore freeze
then we're going to import cysts for
system and then we're also going to
import mat plot live because we gotta
and so the next thing we're going to go
ahead and do is alright so yeah so first
we'll do base equals none now for the
most of you that should work if you end
up having a problem with base later on
comment below and I'll do my best to
help you guys out
but anyway so do that and then we'll
throw a quick if statement here so if
syste platform is equal to win32 so
that's the case then we're actually
going to say the base is instead win32
GUI like so I'm on a 64-bit machine so
this won't really do anything for me but
if you're on 32-bit you'll hopefully
find that that solves one of the
problems next we're going to specify the
executables section of our
so now we're going to say executables
and this is going to equal a list
basically and in here we basically put a
bunch of the parameters so first you say
what we're going to execute what is the
base of that execution and then anything
else added on to it in our case we we
have a window icon and so we kind of
want that icon to stick all the way
through so it'll be like the actual icon
and the executable so that's kind of
neat so we'll do that as well so first
of all the executables is going to equal
see X underscore capital F freeze dot
capital e executable and then the first
parameter here is going to be the actual
file name of what we're executing or
what we're going to convert in our in my
case anyways that's tkinter vid 28
whatever your file name is put it in
obviously dot PI base is going to equal
base no problem
and then icon for the actual you know
program icon we're going to use client
icon ICO so that's the icon that I made
way long ago if you don't have the exact
same icon sorry but if you made a window
icon you can throw that in there
otherwise you know you don't have to
leave that there if you don't want to
and that's it for executables now we're
going to do CX freeze dot setup and then
here's where we put in basically all of
our setup
you know parameters and stuff so first
what we're going to add here is the name
and this is just the name of the client
basically and we're going to call it C
of BD c - client so that's the name then
we're going to do we're going to add a
bunch of options here and this is where
this is pretty much where things get
tricky and so if you're coming across a
certain problem or they have a very
specific task that you're looking to do
with CX freeze it really helps to go
read the docs so I'm one of these people
that really does not like to read
documentation I prefer to just look at
sample code the problem is not very many
people use CX freeze and a lot of people
haven't encountered maybe the same
problems that you've encountered or at
least they haven't shared their um
they're basically answers to those
problems so kind of like here I couldn't
really find a good answer
to my problems so here I am sharing my
answer with you guys but not too many
people end up doing that with CX freeze
just because it's a lesser used module
and slightly confusing sometimes so
anyway check the docs if you're having
problems we have a very specific
scenario that you're trying to encompass
so moving right along options is going
to equal the following so first on we
have the build underscore exe option and
that is going to distance dictionaries
that that key goes to the following so
we have first packages and these are
packages that the the application is
using and we're actually using two major
packages here that we want to explicitly
call and that's t king tur and matt plot
live the other stuff is kind of
acceptable so for example tkinter you
don't necessarily always have to import
or specify explicitly that you're using
tkinter cs freezes is pretty darn good
about figuring that out especially if
you have like a really basic tkinter
application but what happens is like a
lot of like dialogue stuff mostly it's
dialogue but some other things just
don't come over for whatever reason I
don't know but sometimes you can just
explicitly say hey I'm using tkinter
matplotlib and whatever else
usually it's third party modules that
you need to really be specific about but
tkinter is not a third party module and
i still had to do it so just keep that
in mind so the package is tkinter
matplotlib and then what we're going to
go ahead and do is we're also going to
add another thing here and it's gonna be
include underscore files now keep in
mind what we're doing here this is all
under this parameter right or I'm sorry
yet so like right here and here's this
is what's pertaining to build exe okay
so include files um really we just have
a single include file at the moment we
may find ourselves having a lot more
later on but for now it's just client
icon dot ICO and don't confuse that
again it's my understanding here that
this is the icon for the actual
executable application
this is the icon that will show up in
the its this is where you put included
files in your actual Python script okay
so like let's say you had an image or
something like an image for a button
okay this that's where you would in
included files that's where you would
put that that image path okay and these
are in the same directory as the script
that's why they're just straight up the
image name if they're not like say they
were in a folder called includes or
something you would obviously need to do
include slash and so on so um so that's
that um and now we're ready to add we
can add a few more things like for
example we can add version and when you
say version equals and this is actually
a string but 0.01 and then you can add a
description and we'll say the
description is C of BC trading
application something like that comma
and then finally executables and then
that's just gonna equal execute
executables just like that no period
okay so man just like so itchy
I don't know this video probably come
out I don't even know how much long from
from this date that I'm filming it but
it's pretty much down the way is maybe
even a month but anyway I'm from like
South Texas from Houston is really humid
in Houston and we're getting now I'm up
in in Fort Worth and it's extremely dry
up here like it's nice in this the
summer time because the humidity down in
Houston is brutal but man the dryness
here I'm like cracking up my heel is all
crys disgusting like how dry I am it
sucks
um anyway moving on um so that's it for
a stepped-up hi file boom done
next what we need to do is we need to
open up our let's see
syntax lessons and then we'll come over
to uh the tkinter mega series here so
come over to the directory that's
housing your actual script
hold shift right click and open in a
command window
so inside tkinter mega series is where
all these scripts are and number 28 is
what we're going to convert but we're
going to use obviously set up top hi so
the set up hi file by the way is you
know right here okay so this is where I
am so now what we want to do is under in
within tkinter mega series here to see
if I can make this big nah I ran into
this problem before so my text will like
run off the screen but it should come
out down here anyway um so tkinter mega
series and the way that we can run CX
frees is the following so python set up
pi and then type build now couple of
things might happen you might have
python is not recognized if that is the
case um then you need to type C colon
slash Python 34 Python set up top high
build okay um I'll show you that in a
minute
otherwise you can also run out of memory
that's a bug I don't run out of memory
when I do this but whatever reason I get
that bug from time to time
no module name CX freeze we miss we type
at C expertise here capital F there save
let's go back so for example that was
proper coat right I did have Python but
if it says his Python is not recognized
you could do C colon slash Python 34
Python if you're using Python 3.4
Python and then setup dot pi build
that's not an enter by the way that just
is the line running over hit enter now
so now it's running the build again I
might run out of memory just cuz it has
some bug but looks like we're going to
make it this time
cool it's really annoying is to fix that
I have to restart and it's really just
quite annoying so once that's done now
you're ready to go into the mega series
here and you should have a new folder
called build double click on build
double click on this and here you have
all your build files now we're going to
find that we have a problem most likely
but that's ok so here's your application
you could double click on it and it
would run but for everyone it shouldn't
run and you should get this error here
probably that says name err quit is not
defined so we've been using pythons
built-in quit for whatever reason it
does not want us to get away with that
so hit ok that's
we'll come on down or let's go back we
can delete build we'll have to build one
more time come on down to your your
original script open that up and within
here these might give us some trouble
too and a little bit the fonts will
likely give trouble but we'll come back
to those Oh - uh so the problem is quit
okay so now see we reference this quit
function so for example let's just type
quit and so we see command equals quit
in a bunch of places so what we're going
to do is we can base it what we can do
is say actually we can probably just
over overpower the built in quit so
let's go to up to the very very top here
and just do this do this define quit and
then quit and that should be good enough
so let's save that come back to your
build right here and just hit the up
arrow one time and then rebuild it again
hopefully don't write memory I mean
angry I know it's gonna happen on one of
these I want to restart it's so so
annoying when that happens it looks like
we're gonna get away with it again
oh yeah so now back to the mega series
here up to build let's see if font gives
us the trouble so run the executable
looks like we got away with it so here
is our executable we can hit agree and
here's our lovely program being run as
an executable look at that lovely lovely
ICO we'll have to update our ICO to not
be so pixely in the bar but that's what
I mean when you went for the icons like
the actual program icon but yeah so
everything you know pretty much works
you can chain what we basically went
from one day to a day you should have
everything working from here we'll make
sure that you know like we're able to
use yep everything should keep running
at Magdy at the bottom all right so
that's that we've converted to an
executable another interesting thing
that you can do um actually two things I
want to show you guys really quick the
first thing is it looks like it didn't
do it maybe we've got a nice
they actually know I see em okay so so
if we check the size of this build we
see the size is 314 megabytes the reason
or part of the reason why it's that big
is we have the these saw all this Syfy
and numpy stuff basically all of this
well if we look back at our script we
don't use Syfy or while we're importing
numpy here oops so we do use numpy I
forget what we're actually using numpy
404 the array what we do so we use some
of numpy um but if you even have if you
just have Syfy and up I installed as a
Matt are as a Python module you're going
to get this nonsense okay and you just
don't need it and I'm pretty sure most
of this stuff we don't need um we might
need some one of them will probably need
but for example you should like with SCI
PI we could just highlight all these sy
PI's most likely okay and we could
delete them and now we still have some
pretty large none pause but now our file
is a 118 megabyte so we lost 200
megabytes there and whoops let's go back
into the build here and hopefully won't
get near Excel feel that click on the
icon yeah uh uh where is our pro there
it is hopefully it'll show up yeah okay
so so here's our program we just we
didn't need those things okay in the
same thing with numpy now we are using
numpy so one of these that we probably
need um but just for kicks let's just
delete a hole see if we can get okay
skip because we're using ah man okay so
these are being corporated for some
reason I guess but um but yeah so so
that's that and there's only there's one
more thing I wouldn't mind showing you
guys um and that is to convert this into
an actual installer so what we can do is
and when we go to build it let's see I
guess I close out of the window so let
me get back into the command window and
now what you can do instead is you can
say
something like this you can say Python
set up pi and then you can make an msi
so the dist underscore msi this is only
if you're on Windows and I'm on a 64-bit
machine so this will make a 64-bit
installer for this application so if you
wanted to make a 32-bit installer you
would need to be on a 32-bit computer
access tonight what mmm-maybe cuz we're
right let me let's delete the original
build here and before it's like you
can't delete it yeah
brick oh oh that's irritating eh
okay um let's just create a quick quick
workaround here um let's call this that
take the client icon and tkinter vid 28
hopefully you guys aren't falling but
then copy those to this temporary folder
jerk oh and then they also set up that
PI so let's copy that into our temporary
folder and then now to open up the
temporary folder maybe notice that get
away from that like a closed application
a long time ago and it's not letting me
delete the cuz it says open but it's
it's not so that's quite quite
irritating anyway so build our uh this
one is what we want to go into so let's
open command window there and then
pythons setup dot pi be distort MSI um
so this makes a installer hopefully we
won't get an error this time this will
make an installer for uh for 64-bit
machine and if you're on Mac I forget
the command but Mac does also have a
similar thing where you can make like a
Mac application
I forget the code but just you can look
it up probably pretty easily so once
this is done this part takes a little
bit to make the final folder that we're
looking for so we'll just wait but
anyway now whenever we run this we'll be
able to choose like what directory do we
want this application installed to and
all that and it's just a single
application
um at first anyways when you install it
it gives you the entire build like you
had before um but it's you know one
thing that you have to share with
somebody rather than you know the whole
folder I suppose you could zip up the
folder and share that with people or
something but this is just a little
slightly more condensed way to share
your program so everything should be
done I forget if it throw it yes so
threw it into distribution so it's just
just this simple folder or the file
rather 113 megabytes so now we can
double click that it's computing space
requirements bla bla bla bla bla
apparently it's really taxing to compute
these space requirements there we go so
I can install it to program files
um I should also be able to install it
basically right here so like let's let's
install it to to this so install it to
this path here all the way to this file
and then /c a BDC client ok we've route
so it should make a new directory here
uh got it either Java or this yeah so
I'm not really sure sometimes it cuts
out the recording when those things pop
up but I had like a window for if I
needed to like accept accept the
installation anyway so then now we have
this new directory double click that and
think there's the exact same stuff we
were looking at before and here's our
application that we can you know run and
use so anyways that's that if you guys
have any questions or comments or
concerns what amber with converting your
application to an executable please do
feel free to leave your comments below
otherwise as always thanks for watching
thanks for all the support subscriptions
and the donations and until next time